Mark block here, Mark block here.
My tattoo itches. Um,
anyway dude. Wow. Brian Callan called me,
Joe coy called me name,
dropping man name dropping city, dude. Oh,
name-dropping city. Um, anyway, uh, yeah,
BTS looks like video games and they know it.
That McDonald's doc, you got to see it, dude. That guy is just awesome.
Hmm.
I got a GRA I don't remember who I was talking to. This was recent.
This was this, this week. I'm like they were saying something like,
yeah. Oh, that I'm not going to say who it was.
Cause he's a buddy of mine and I love him, but he's like,
dude got a place out in, uh,
the desert. And I was like, Hey,
what? And he said, yeah, I bought a home out in the desert.
It's not even barely a home.
It's like a little can that like I just decorated.
I said, yeah. And he said, yup, anytime you want to go. And in my head I went,
Whoa, Whoa, Whoa, let me stop you right there. I'm Chris D'Elia.
Did you think maybe you were talking to someone else, did you for a second?
Think I was the Fisher King.
So he said, yeah. You know, and I just going to go out there sometimes.
It's just to unplug, let me ask you a question, man. This is the thing.
And it's been around for a long time. Ever since we like invented a microwave,
why do people need to unplug?
I truly think if you're someone who values unplugging
your like a drama queen drama, King,
uh, not level-headed insane person.
He sat it. He sat
at.
Why do you need to unplug dude? What's up, dude. What's going on with that?
You plugged in. Is that what it is? You plugged into much when people are like,
God, you know what? I'm so glad I left my phone at home.
It felt great. Just walking around unplugging.
It felt great. Just being out,
camping in the middle of nowhere next to a Creek,
I just had to unplug even for a few days. And now I feel recharged,
dude. You know what? Recharges you a salad,
a burger.
You don't have to sleep on to unplug.
That's a getting new,
I guess Western philosophy thing where it's like we have it's
so good that you just can't have it. Good.
You're you're guilt. You. We have it so good. We invented walls.
We invented microwaves. There's a toaster out there, dude.
You could put your bread that we manufactured by the way in a toaster
and turn it into hot bread. That's better.
And because we've got it that good.
You think you got to unplug and be away from the toaster so you can
recharge and be a stress-free better person. Well,
let me tell you something guy who does that.
You're just terrible at bass
at bass, ER, terrible.
You don't need to unplug. You can go on vacation, fine experience.
Another thing. Cool. Go to Hawaii, go to Bali.
Lay in a hot but sleep in a bedroom, man.
You know why?
Because we made bedrooms and it took us so many centuries
and, and, and thousands and thousands Mo millennia. What do you call them?
Millennial mullet, millennias, millenniums,
whatever the. That word is that part. Millennial, you know,
we've spent thousands and thousands of years coming up with these
impossible thread thread counts, man. And you're going to go lay on a
rock. You just don't get how to be, man.
I get our millennia. That's what it is.
And I get how our eyes are adjusting because now we're looking at clothes
screens all the time and our eyesights are worse than it was.
But dude adapt like the tadpole man. You're not a tadpole.
You're a frog. And that's a beautiful thing.
You think the frog has ever like, ah, man, I hate these legs. No,
they're just jumping from Lily pad to Lily pad going rebut,
enjoying their frog sense. Enjoy your human,
man. unplugging. I don't trust anybody. One plugs,
plugin unplugging all the time. Dude. You know where my phone is ever here.
You know, wherever my phone is, you know what? I've never lost my phone.
And I lost my phone. One time.
It was in like 2008 and I'll never lose it again because I've been plugged in
since then.
I left the diner at the standard hotel downtown and I left and I walked
back and it wasn't there. And that was one of my favorite phones.
It was one of those ones that slides out like that.
And it looked like you were in the matrix,
but whatever I've been plugged in ever since and some was talking to me for some
reason so long. No man, I was no way.
It wasn't 2008 that like iPhone. It was like 2002. Anyway,
it doesn't matter. When did the cell phones start? Yeah, I was like 2003
in August, 2019 in August. Uh, uh, 1999.
Everybody got a cell phone.
I left, I went to Vancouver to shoot a movie, came back.
Everyone had a cell phone and everyone was playing snake.
Um, yeah dude, I, you can't trust these people who say they unplug,
you just can't. You can't trust them with like secrets, bro.
You're going to go unplug and change. That's the thing, man.
You've become who you are. And anytime you shift that,
like one time I was going out with this chick and she was like, Hey,
I bought a chick. I bought a, uh, um, an airplane ticket to Paris.
I'm just going to go for two weeks. And I was like, what?
When she was like in a month and I was like, you didn't like tell me before.
She's like, I just knew if I didn't buy it, I wasn't, I wasn't going to go.
And I was like, Oh, we've been together for like two years.
You just got to come buy a ticket to Paris and just go, sure enough.
She went there. She came back. She broke up with me. Oh, Holy, dude.
We love, we love predictable people, man.
We love predictable people and I knew it was going to happen. And it happened.
If you let your girlfriend go somewhere for two weeks at a country,
you might as well break up with her for real. Same goes for guys. Girl,
if you let your dude just take a trip for two weeks,
guess what? See you later. You might as well move out right there.
Yeah.
Well when my son grows up, that's what I'm going to tell him. No, no, no, no,
no, no, no, no. Dude, you go from going away for two weeks, find a new girl.
He's gonna be like, but yeah, no, no, but honestly that's how it's going to be.
They leave and they find out some more about life and then they, they, they,
they're going to be like, I think we grew apart. That's the other thing too.
We don't grow apart with people, bro. If you're, I don't know.
It's whatever I, what am I even talking about at this point? It, it does.
You know what? We could sum it up like this. Well that's quick. I like it.
Slower. Better. Yeah, dude.
Um, anyway, what else was I wanted to talk about?
I don't even remember.
Should I do the last ad that we had a another ad today because of
BII eggs. When you remember when, uh, dub see when B
I, when dub, when dub C from the West coast connection.
When B I H I thought, well,
okay. I love dub is one of my favorite rappers. What side can it go?
When he goes West side, can a gang, can a gang bang, bang, bang,
and then goes West side in the back. Oh,
West side clinic. Bing, Bing bang. Hey,
you're 40, you know,
West CFL. Leah, Nia. Uh, just say it,
just say West side for life. N word was, see a Familia.
Nia. You're 40
dude. I love it.